belloubet hier soir à l'assemblée elle a
dit il faut réformer l'ordonnancé de 45
leur donnant de 45 c'est ce texte qui
régit la justice des mineurs un texte
sensible qui dans lequel souvent
l'idéologie l'emportent sur le
pragmatisme on en parle mais on regarde
d'abord ce qu'a dit la ministre de la
justice
nous devons juger plus vite les mineurs
pour qu'ils prennent conscience de la
gravité de leurs actes lorsque c'est le
cas et nous devons aussi prendre des
mesures qui soient adaptés à chaque
profil de ces jeunes délinquants sans
angélisme et sans démagogie c'est
pourquoi je vous annonce que dans le
cadre de la loi pour la réforme de la
justice le gouvernement sollicitera du
parlement une habilitation pour réformer
l'ordonnancé de 1945 par la création
d'un code de justice pénale des mineurs
jugés plus vite les mineurs vous
applaudissez des dommages il ce matin le
choix de le choix de faire cette réforme
par ordonnance est quand même étonnant
parce que c'est un enjeu c'est pas
normal ça mais répondait déjà sur la
question il faut juger trop vite
est ce que c'est une émission jugée plus
vite je ne sais pas un professionnel la
justice par contre ce que je sais c'est
que l'homme comme à peu près tous les
syndicats aujourd'hui pratiquement
des zones où il ya ce qu'il faut surtout
c'est faire en sorte que les décisions
du qui sont prises aujourd'hui pour la
justice des enfants et des adolescents
soient appliquées ce qui n'est pas du
tout le cas
c'est à dire exécution c'est aujourd'hui
vous avez un phénomène qui existe dans
des dizaines de tribunaux en france
c'est qu'entre le moment où un juge
prend une mesure concernant un enfant ou
un adolescent elle au moment où cette
mesure elle est effective il peut se
passer trois mois six ans et demi pour
avoir des comptes à bobigny où la
situation est absolument dramatique
les 15 juges du tribunal pour enfants et
quinze ont signé ensemble c'est très
rare un texte pour dire nous sommes
devenus les juges de mesures fictives
c'est quand même parce que parce que on
mesure par exemple de que l'enfant soit
déplacé dans tel endroit etc
il faut attendre 18 mois ouais pour que
l'éducateur ne comprends pas c'est à
dire que le mineur
quelqu'un qui a commis un acte
délictueux ne comprends pas qu on le
sanctionne du mois après parce qu'il est
déjà quelqu'un d'autre d'ailleurs à
l'époque elle a raison et nicole
belloubet de dire
pour réformer l'ordonnancé de 45 oui
sans doute mais le problème ne réside
pas là le problème réside dans
l'éducation dans le soutien aux familles
résident enfin voila je sais pas ce que
ça veut dire quoi c'est à dire durcir
les peines aussi parce que l'exemption
de minorité aujourd'hui c'est diviser
par deux la peine quand on a entre 16 et
18 ans donc ça supposerait aussi
d'aggraver ces peines ou finalement de
garder la peine qui a été pensée par les
magistrats comme toujours c'est une
possibilité de le faire non plus donc
voila moi ce qui me frappe c'est que
la plupart de ces enfants délinquants
prédélinquants sont souvent de familles
monoparentales avec des femmes qui ne
vont tourner vers ceux auxquels on ne
verse pas les pensions alimentaires les
maris ou les ex mari ne verse pas
l'essentiel des pensions alimentaires ou
les ex compagnon est en train de faire
un sud sur la pauvreté qu'on vous cache
et deux ou trois millions de familles
monoparentales avec des femmes qui
serait ce que j'ai quitté leur job pour
garder leurs gosses pour pouvoir les
emmener à l'école le matin et c'est un
vrai une vraie désespérance donc la
justice ne suffit pas c'est à dire s'est
il faut de l'accompagnement tous les
plans sur tous les plans et je me
rappelle d'ailleurs à mayotte j'avais vu
un colonel qui commande est un une école
de deuxième chance dans lesquels on met
ces prêts délinquants pour essayer de le
remettre dans le bon chemin et
millénaire un peu désabusé mise et c'est
fou parce que finalement pendant trente
ans on a démoli les valeurs morales
trimballer notamment est véhiculée par
la chose militaire
et aujourd'hui c'est à nous qu'on ne
rentrent et part et la société et de
remettre les les enfants dans le droit
chemin en leur redonnant un peu le sens
d ôter la discipline je sais pas si vous
avez vu général de villiers d'ailleurs
dans on n'est pas couché samedi dernier
ils étaient formidables cet âge est
temps d'y aller c'est marrant parce que
ils étaient accueillis
christine angot et et laurent wauquiez
enfin avait beaucoup de considération
pour lui ça aurait pu être le cas il ya
temps j'ai envoyé une petite révolution
culturelle et morale c'est quand même la
moindre des choses à voir un peu de
considération si on regarde son parcours
son regard son parcours mineur mais
c'est ce que la gauche antimilitariste
ya 20 ou 30 ans démolition des consignes
indisciplinés
faire l'émission formés mais j'aimerais
vous entendre aussi sur le côté je peux
suivre nicolas sarkozy croit disait un
jeune de 16 ans aujourd'hui en 2018 mais
ne ressemble pas à celui de 45 donc il
ya matière à réforme oui il faut
réformer cette ordonnance tous les
professionnels le disent d'abord parce
que c'est pas du tout un totem c'est un
texte qui a été bougés près de 40 fois
aujourd'hui c'est un millefeuille il
faut mettre de la clarté il faut
reprendre ce texte s'il faut reprendre
ce texte avec pour moi deux principes à
respecter le premier c'est la recherche
de réponses éducatives
il faut construire des parcours pour ces
jeunes pour les aider à sortir à ne pas
rentrer plus tôt dans des parcours de
délinquance il faut que les sanctions
soient des sanctions qui ait un sens
éducatif
ce qui veut dire des sanctions qui sont
appliquées rapidement et ce qui veut
dire qu' un accompagnement vraiment des
jeunes pour qui il ya un sens qu'ils
comprennent là où a été la faute et
pourquoi ils ne doivent pas rêver 17
fautes ça c'est un point qui me paraît
essentiel dans la réforme qu'il faut
conduire
le deuxième point qui me paraît
essentielle c'est que oui il faut garder
le principe de l'atténuation de la
responsabilité en fonction de la justice
attention sans les médias nicole
belloubet faisons cette réforme sans
angélisme et sans démagogie non plus un
paraît essentiel attention parce que la
démagogie elle arrive très souvent deux
extraits de leur côté six daims
rapidement sur ce sujet mais je tiens
quand même un art a souligné mon accord
avec ce point de forme essentielle c'est
un texte qui aurait dû être débattu au
parlement et pas seulement à dakar avec
la voix d'anne en bois formant ses pas
et pas à terre ou au beurre de l'ampleur
du sujet un dernier mot peut-être marque
sur le sujet
qu'est ce qui vous paraît le plus urgent
parce que on dit je vous pose la
question aussi parce que la justice est
un des secteurs où on dit toujours il ya
peu de moyens il faut augmenter les
budgets c'est le parent pauvre des
budgets là c'est un secteur où
effectivement il ya peut-être urgence
il ya urgence et de toute façon tous les
efforts budgétaires qui seront faits en
faveur de la justice seront jamais
suffisant parce qu on part de tellement
bas qu'il faudrait il faudrait
complètement révolutionné l'ordre des
choses pour faire en sorte que vous
parlez avec bobigny effectivement c'est
un scandale national d'état ce qui se
passe là-bas pour inverser l'ordre des
choses donc emmanuel macron lui mais un
milliard mais un milliard de plus sur le
quinquennat sur le ministre de la
justice c'est beaucoup c'est 20% en plus
ça sera pas suffisant et tout de toute
façon quand on voit la pauvreté la
misère dans laquelle la justice ait
répondu en france fin se rend en france
chérie on est les bras m'en tombent
alors ceux de nos internautes en tout
cas leur voix on va aller on va
l'entendre faut-il créer comme le
souhaite nicole belloubet à code de la
justice pénale pour les mineurs
en gros c'est faut-il réformer
l'ordonnancé 45 oui à 70% si je nous dit
je suis mitigé un gamin de 14 ans n'a
rien à faire en prison
et il ajoute un ado délinquance ouvre
souvent d'une carence familiale nicole
elle n'est pas tout à fait d'accord
enfin en tout cas elle dit nous sommes
trop laxiste avec les mineurs
délinquants
voilà pour ce soir en tout cas sur le
ces différents sujets en un mot on a on
n'a même pas eu on a dépassé mes
pronostics pour pour la coupe davis
marque parce que je sens que vous êtes
frustré de pas avoir parlé du sujet la
france sur terre battue face aux deux
membres du top ten
crois tu savais très dur mais on va
gagner d'accord pas d'accord
gilles c'est la dernière coupe davis
dans telle qu'on la connaît dans cette
formule qui est magnifique et qui
malheureusement va être supprimé donc
oui c'est normal
voilà oui exactement ben voilà donc
willy yannick noah est capable d'emmener
encore la france au bout merci beaucoup
à tous les cas merci à vous de nous
avoir suivis vous avez rendez vous
demain avec guillaume roquette pour un
nouveau point de vue
[Musique]